- I've seen a cat take a shit
locking eyes with my roommate.
Not many people can say that, so. (laughs)
(light electronic music)
- I have a cat and her name is Jengi.
- His name is Rusty Shackleford.
- My cat's name is Tails.
- Meano.
- So I missed having Harry with me
so I flew him out to LA from Dallas.
- And he was kinda standing near the wall,
and I was petting him, and he started
having a sneezing fit.
- He had this problem where he
(intense inquisitive music)
didn't go to the bathroom
for like three days,
and then he started acting like
he was possessed by demons.
- And then all of a sudden,
from the living room
I hear this scream, and it's my roommate.
He's like, "What the fuck, dude?!"
- And it just splattered
all over the wall.
- Some shit flew out of his butt
in liquid form onto my shirt.
- "Dude, your cat fuckin'
shit all over the bean bag,
and I'm eatin' Chipotle!"
- I guess her tail had been under her
and like her whole dump
went on top of her tail.
So like three turds
were on her whole tail.
- A shit longer than him
came out of him, and I have
no idea how it happened.
- This huge Lovesac in the living room
was just drenched in diarrhea,
(light orchestral music)
cat diarrhea, and it just smells.
It's like a shit sauna,
it's just in your face.
(splatting imitation)
- The sheer weight of
the poop on her tail,
she couldn't handle it.
I don't know why she didn't
feel it happening in the midst,
but there was nothing in the litter box.
(music cuts out)
- And then he walked away, and my roommate
was like, "I think we need
to get rid of this cat.
"I don't think it's working out."
- And he told me, "Get rid of the cat,
"the cat's gotta go or I'm gonna go."
(light smooth jazz)
We're not friends anymore
now, but for other issues.
- I don't know, cats are cats.
- It's kind of a
sacrifice you have to make
if you want a cat, you know?
But I love cats so much that it's worth
goin' through some shit storms.